من بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد
الياس اهلا بك كيف تقرا مراحل التقدم
وتاخر في الجبهات الاكثر اشتعالا في
اوكرانيا خاصه الان عندما نتحدث عن تقدم
في باخمه كما يقول الجانب الاوكراني مع
استمرار الوتيره بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
مياده هناك ثلاثه محاور اوكرانيه مهمه جدا
الاكثر انجازا بالمعنى التكتيكي هي في
مخمود لانها استمرار للمعركه السابقه مع
يعني يحدث هناك تقدم المحور الثاني
نوفوسيلكا في الوسط والهدف دائما هو
الوصول الى الجنوب الى
شاطئ بحر ازوف الخط الثاني او المحور
الثالث هو عبر اوريكيف توك ماك وبالتالي
والهدف دائما هو الوصول الى
الحدود مع شبه جزيره قرن هذه ثلاثه محاور
هي الاساسيه اليوم وكل تقدم او غير تقدم
هو من ضمن هذا الهدف لقطع الجسر البري
الروسي ودائما من ضمن الاستراتيجيه الكبرى
ضرب العمق الروسي
اللوجستيه خاصه الجسور المتواجده في
شبه جزيره قرم من كرش الى شمبار الى زين
كوي كل هذه الطرق التي تمول كل التواجد
العسكري الروسي في جنوب اوكرانيا في الوقت
الذي يسعى فيه ذا جانب الاوكراني الى قطع
الامدادات العسكريه عن القوات الروسيه
والمواليه لها في المقابل الجانب الروسي
يقول ان كل الاسلحه التي مدت بها اوكرانيا
من قبل الغرب لم تحدث فرقا في الميدان هل
هذه مقاربه دقيقه
النوعيه مقابل الكميه يتمتع الجيش الروسي
بكميه كبيره من العديد والعتاد وهو كان
لديه الوقت الكافي للتحصن والتحصينات
والخنادق وما شابه على طول الجبهه التي
تمتد 900 كيلومتر اليوم نحن امام من يريد
الخرق ومن هناك من هو يدافع وكان لديه
الوقت وعاده بالريشو مياده بين المهاجم
والمدافع يجب ان يكون لكل مدافع ثلاثه
مهاجمين وهذا امر تفتقده اوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى عدم تزويدها بسلاح اساسي
يحمل قوات المتقدمه الدفاعات الجويه من
هنا التركيز دائما على الطلب الاف 16 نحن
في مرحله طويله الامد الهدف دائما الغربي
والاوكراني ان لا يصل هذا الهجوم الى نقطه
الذروه حيث يقف ونصل الى مرحله ما يسمى
بستلميت ولم يعد هناك قدره اوكرانيه على
احداث الخرق امام حرب نفسها طويل عميد
الياس الطائرات الاف 16 الان برايك في اي
مرحله نحن وصلنا فيما يتعلق بان تحصل
اوكرانيا عليها بعد كل الموافقات والتدريب
على الطيارين من قبل الطيارين عليها هل
اقتربنا من ان تدخل ساحه المعركه
القرار السياسي اتخذ التدريب يستلزم
الطيارين ثلاثه اشهر ولكن مياده عندما
نتحدث عن الابسط عشر انها منظومه كامله
شامله تبدا من الطيار تبدا من التدريب
تبدا من المناوره تبدا من عناصر
التعهد تبدا من الذخيره تبدا من اين
ستنطلق من ضمن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي ان يدرب التيار على الطيران في
هذه الطائره هو غير ان يقاتل ويدعم القوات
الجويه او القوات الارضيه نحن في مرحله
بسيطه يعني بالحد الادنى انا اعتقد من
ثلاثه اشهر الى سته اشهر لنرى الاف 16 هذا
اذا حصل هذا الامر اشكرك من بيروت العميد
ليصحنه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي